it's just so
weird because it's the first disease
that's been hyper politicized
yes which is insane which is unfortunate
because i just read something where it
said like
like a record high 16 percent of
americans
don't trust the vaccine or something
like that because of the politics
well you know when i so it's it's
interesting because
when i worked in covert influence you
know there was a lot of
a lot of thought put into messaging
right so when all the
epidemic was going or when the pandemic
was going on or is going on
like what bothered me the most was the
messaging like they're
like every country had
different messaging and then some of the
messaging was
terrifying and some of it was
not at all helped like was like ignoring
the fact that anything was going on at
all
and i'm like where is the messaging that
like
science is working on it you know we
don't have definitive answers
we think this is happening you know
there's there just wasn't a lot of
you know it's it's hard when like
statements are put out there like
you must wear a mask and you must be six
feet apart
and this is what's going to save you
when that's not actually scientifically
accurate they think
they think at this moment that those
things will be helpful
and that those things will mitigate you
getting it or how sick you get
if you do get it like it just wasn't i
felt like they're just
it wasn't caveated enough like there
wasn't enough information around it they
were trying to do these sound bites
that aren't really accurate and then now
you know
now that all people are being vaccinated
i you see more and more people getting
confused about do i wear a mask or do i
not wear a mask like
i've been vaccinated but i had coveted
like do we both have the same antibodies
like
we just don't wear masks like yeah and
because there's no
clear like what you know when all the
lockdowns were happening i'm like what
is the expectation for these lockdowns
because
it i thought it became clear pretty
quickly
that the expectation the a realistic
expectation for any of the lockdowns
was not eradication new zealand was the
only one
that was like we're going to lock down
fully and we're going to eradicate
but sorry for new zealand you are part
of the rest of the world so even if
you've eradicated it on your islands
like
the real goal there
is to eradicate until there's a vaccine
and we can get our vaccine pop you know
our population vaccinated
and then we can open like that's a more
realistic goal right like
the real goal for the lockdowns was to
not overwhelm the hospitals
it was not so that nobody got sick like
that was never
like people not catching coronavirus
people not getting coveted
is not actually a realistic goal our
hospital systems not being overwhelmed
so that people who would normally be
able to get proper care cannot
and die like unnecessarily like
that's a goal right like that
and it but it was never being said i'm
like that seems to be the clear purpose
we're just trying not to overwhelm the
hospitals but nobody's saying it
so now everybody's like mask shaming and
there's always confusion about
you know when are we gonna end the
lockdown and all this criticism about oh
they ended the lockdown too early not
not you know not early enough like
you know it just it wasn't clear i saw
something really funny i think it was on
vice yesterday where
there's a group of anti-masters
who are now going to start wearing masks
to protect themselves against vaccinated
[Laughter]
i read an article about some that was
hilarious
private school superintendent who is
telling her
telling the teachers that they couldn't
come back if they were vaccinated
because they would be a risk
i just don't like i don't know
yeah who knows i mean who knows it's
hard it's hard that's the problem with
all of it with everything with all of
this tribalism and the
political climate it's the it's
impossible to understand what to
know what's real or what's not and
science is slow
right like science is working on it it
is slow
i've heard a lot of people say you know
i don't want to get vaccinated now
because we're still in the clinical
trials i get that
yeah totally i can totally empathize
with you especially if somebody's
pregnant and they don't want and they're
i can totally emphasize with a mother
that's pregnant and doesn't want to get
the vaccine because they don't know how
to affect their child
exactly or if you have like an immune
disorder or something right like you
don't want to chance it right you don't
know what's going to happen
i get that i think as long as we're all
being honest like
you know i think as long as people are
aware like
be honest that like the vaccines are in
clinical trials right now like
everybody's being vaccinated as part of
this giant clinical trial right like
we're not going to know for a long time
any repercussions we're not going to
know for a long time
if we need boosters or how long these
vaccines are going gonna work we're not
gonna i mean there's tons of stuff we
don't know
because science is working on it and we
just have to be patient and try to keep
up with updates like if you try to force
the hand of a scientist to give you a
direct
answer like give me you know tell me
exactly what's happening
you know this is the one and final
answer they can't do that
right and if they if they do do that
then that should be a huge red flag to
you
that whatever they're saying is not
accurate right you know
scientists shouldn't try to act like
they have the answers to everything
their goal is to ask questions not to
exactly like they should be telling you
we think we know this now
we think this now but that's the extent
of it
right you know and you have to be open
another weird thing about the uh
the vaccines a really good friend of
mine had
had cancer when he was a child and he
had like ungodly amounts of
radiation in chemo and uh
it affected his body quite strangely
like it like there's certain things that
that really [ __ ] him up like if he has a
beer
he's hung over the next day for like the
whole day wow and like different
different little quirky things with
with him and um when
i had my first kid he went and got a
tdap shot
mm-hmm oh that's nice of him yeah it was
very nice yeah he's a super nice guy
um and uh because he wanted to hang out
with us and he loves kids so he wanted
to hang out with the kid and um
and the tdap shot literally had him like
in horrific night sweats for like 24
hours
he was like he could barely eat he could
barely breathe
he thought he was gonna die after he got
that shot wow and
he just got the coveted vaccine and he
said nothing really
so it's interesting how different
vaccines are different whatever
how they affect the body in different
ways depending on yeah
who you are and just like the same thing
with with the different viruses like the
way
andy caught ding gay and it affected him
like that my wife had chronovirus she
got it
she was like deathly ill for 10 days
wow and i was around her the whole time
like helping her and doing everything i
never got it i never even caught it i
didn't catch it either i was right there
with them
yeah yeah so it's just it's really
interesting
to me it's one of those things like you
never know how the virus is going to
affect you
you never know how the vaccine is going
to affect you i find like
i find biology to be like this super
inaccurate science because there's so
many factors right like your body's
history
your current state of health i mean
there's you can't guess
i mean you can kind of guess like it's
how i feel about birth control right
like there's
you're trying to change your biology
there's tons of different types of birth
control you have
no idea what any one of those are going
to do to your body right
so you just guess and you kind of hope
for the best
[Laughter]
i